we've all done it we've all done
something insanely stupid gotten the
kill and then justified it with one
single word
worth look sometimes the only way to
secure a kale is to make a hilariously
bad decision to sacrifice yourself for
the greater good to succeed you must
feed but before we get into that i gotta
remind you as always the like button the
subscribe button and to ring the
notification bell without further ado
let's get into the top 10 worth it plays
in esports history
kicking off our list is the time that
device had the burning desire to get the
full five
literally the fleet back to twist as
well he even knows he's coming looks
away sees him and then clatter close
that's his second collateral the ct side
near the end of the final map of iem
global challenge 2020 astralis star
opera device put up an ace for the ages
after securing an opening pick through
mid doors device rotated a to hold off
the long take bagged one more body from
team liquid before he retreated to carr
and waited for his teammates to rotate
unfortunately liquid had every means of
flushing him out elige flashed device
off the angle stewie tossed out the
classic molly counter and twists flanked
from cat device was in a word
screwed but with nowhere to go device
held his ground sure he died but getting
the ace end the round while he was doing
it
that's not just worth that is
undoubtedly the hottest collat of his
career well it is good for one they give
it the respect to get back to the car
that might be their undoing the short
play now from twists oh device reads it
in with the flick burning alive and the
collateral in the flames the ace for
device
taking the ninth spot on our list is the
ill-advised time tsm traded baron for
their nexus oh oh no no no no are we
looking for the back door is it
happening
in pantheon are we going to trade baron
for nexus
that has never been a good one tsm were
struggling in the group stage of worlds
2020. they went into their final bout
against lgd with an abysmal 05 record
all they wanted was to win one single
match just to avoid the cursed donut
it's just it's just for eager to say
that you won some games at worlds
yeah
unfortunately they got so hungry that
when they finally secured a much-needed
pick onto orianna and earned enough
breathing room for what should have been
an extremely viable baron they threw oh
no
are we looking for the back door is it
happening
in pantheon are we going to trade baron
for nexus
that has never been a good one oh no
that's lgd trying to keep them here oh
no
yeah
gonna come in and yes tsm you did manage
to get a baron but can you get out of
here is the question empowered recalls
aren't going to come through but there
are no no
left remaining one comes back there are
four people here can launching do it is
the
see instead of contesting lgd just
walked on down the mid lane straight
into tsm's nexus and
ended
all of it it was a bit of a risky move
and it barely didn't work but they won
the match and crushed the hopes and
dreams of tsm fans everywhere
definitely worth it for lgd though
uppercutting his way into the ace slot
on our list is dark's reminder that
sometimes the best way to go down is to
take the other guy with you
what happens here
in game five of the losers finals at evo
online 2021's latin american division
darks g found himself significantly low
on health in the final round against dd
mccoff's dolphin he's in
what a challenge did mohkov does not
care
fortune's a v reversal that is crazy so
now darkness is not gonna have v trigger
for the comeback but dark didn't bow out
somehow he definitely managed to get dd
milkoff into a last hit situation and in
a random risky moment dark bet it all on
a wake up jab knowing that if he missed
he was dead and if he hit it it would
result in a double ko this is close is
it gonna be are we gonna see a whiff
punch possible
like that mean both players were forced
to run it back in a new final game which
dark swept thanks in part to the mental
reset he got with this totally worth it
double ko
oh my god stunt setting no way
to command though
i mean he didn't go for a reset demo was
holding up the whole time because he was
scared to command craft like you said
and just like that dark wow what a win
that was crazy i mean that was just so
explosive
you went from a draw game to to just
dark just dominating that last game
right there to move on to the green
at number seven is a good old-fashioned
cheese strat that melted dota mines
almost as quickly as it melted melee
raxes up to during and following their
miraculous win at the international 2016
chinese underdogs wings gaming were
world renowned for the ridiculous yet
ingenious cheese strats and the most
worth it one of them all was the
alacrity earth ruling see when invoker
casts alacrity on brewmaster's earth
ruling it gives him an attack speed buff
that lets him walk up to structures and
do this
they have the combo are they going for
they're going in for it straight away
with the ultimate on to the towers the
fortification will come out
they do have all their big goats as well
on eg as we can see they're the brewling
with the alapagey look at it just melt
the t3 turn towards the rat and in fact
look at these racks go down they need to
kill this brew thanks to bruling's
built-in magic immunity and the fact
that it dealt hundreds of damage per
right click wings could spawn it imbue
it with invoker's buff posture behind it
get ready to engage and watch as it
decimated the enemy base
fake piano straight away the primal
split and the electricity here we go the
tornado holding back eg the
fortification is there the best part is
is that it didn't matter if the
brewmaster ended up dying for it as long
as the melee racks got destroyed it was
worth every right click they have all
their ultimates
straight in with the primer split he's
ready to kick it off here sprouting to
weha leaps out away from the circle of
trees oh the tower's down misery's
trying to look for the opening for the
sidelines the great spots of the bkb
moon comes in from the side with the
hook shot eyesight still on the front
lines of it all he's just standing there
playing meleeing up and tanking up the
damage on the side though zacks is out
wings they've found one eye size will be
focused by the damage of resolution
they've taken down the nature's profit
and now they're looking for more
coming in at number six is the draft
designed to make dying worth it in game
two of their semi-final matchup against
team dk at the 2015 heroes of the storm
world championship cloud9 combined
leoric and murky's death-defying
abilities with shields from tassadar and
abathur to make it so that heroes who
wanted to die just couldn't not made to
die we've had a third top of him safety
bubble and now the right wing attempt at
cscc i'm done i'm in now but i'm just
gonna drink here you know i'm gonna
really go down
inflicting slows and maintaining vision
from the grave and murky's demise is
only counting as quarter deaths instead
of full ones they could cause havoc
while their supports use shields
teleports and damage abilities to keep
these inting yet
indestructible carries alive the
craziest part is that cloud91
[Applause]
sitting smack dab in the middle of our
list is one of the closest craziest and
impossibly calculated base races league
of legends has ever seen why because it
involved a player abandoning their nexus
instead of defending it so low the blade
is not able to find him death goes to
the killing spree it's the shy still the
base it's kt look at him trying to stand
and fight if they can the shy has made
his way onto the inhibitor turrets in
game three of their heated quarter-final
bout against invictus gaming at worlds
2018 kt rolster smeb had to shut down
the shy's fiora as she engaged in a one
hero base race against four kt members
there was only one problem that fiora
was way too farmed for smeb to take on
alone the bottom lane but shy has no tp
this is going to be your game ending
push one way or the other it's kt going
for the base it's gonna be a base race
and that's when smeb made a judgment
call as soon as guardian angel revived
him he opted not to fight fiora he
teleported to join his teammates in the
enemy's base instead leaving his nexus
exposed and the shy in the greatest one
versus five structure showdown league
has ever seen hello the blade caller's
not able to find him death goes to the
killing spree it's the shy still in the
base it's kt looking to try to stay in a
fight if they can the shy has made his
way onto the inhibitor turrets onto the
nexus turrets they're going to be taken
down kt is still marching it's a base
race the size of the balloon excess kt
is under the red who's gonna win the shy
will not and kt
takes it to game four holy crap
sometimes abandoning your own base is
totally worth it
steamrolling into the top four is a play
that north american dota fans will never
forget
c9 feeding their racks to secure a win
at ti4 in game 4 of the lower bracket
match between vichy gaming and cloud 9
c9 shocked everyone by picking meepo
yeah that's a good cool
oh
they're gonna bring it back
now vichy had plenty of meepo counters
on their team so they were able to keep
up the oppressive multi-hero mid laner
they secured a crucial pick with aegis
in preparation for the high ground push
and cloud9 knew they wouldn't be able to
put up a fight
they still have vegas they still have oh
that egg is only a 30 seconds but pilot
died four stopped down the rtk gonna be
on the tail end of him and pyle died
well he turns for one last track but he
will die outside the base but with aegis
down in a matter of seconds most of
vichy's meepo counters were ultimates
meaning that they had painfully long
cooldowns and luna's glaives needed to
bounce between buildings to stop the
blink initiation so c9 did the one thing
that you pretty much never ever do in
dota they waited until their racks was
down before taking the fight and what a
fight it was
maybe even more they can rotate towards
the middle lane they have their army of
meatball to force things out and the
tier three tower where else they current
pilot died he's looking to get the early
tracks fiji gaming make their way back
out again the your tier two tower gone
the middle lane and opens up the mid
ranks
thanks to their racks play c9 were able
to wipe vichy decimate their base and
watch as meepo sent their throne into
the shadow realm 1500
it's over
c9 will win
taking home a much deserved bronze is
the time s2j bet it all on the spike
he's hit up there so getting him a lot
of mileage
[Applause]
heading into his first game of a loser's
top eight match against west balls at
evo 2016 s2j really wanted the dub his
record against the falco main was 0 to
11 and he didn't want to just win he
wanted to make a statement unfortunately
for s2j westballz was a little too wily
the match was slowly tipping in west's
favor and s2j had to reassert dominance
so he did something crazy
oh he's he's fixed it up there so
getting him a lot of mileage
okay what's he got here
he's gotta grab the ledge he's gonna
[Applause]
after pulling off a solid edge guard
westballz was still theoretically able
to make it back to the stage s2j decided
to bet the farm on a down air spike
hoping that he wouldn't whiff and fall
to his death and praying that the trade
wouldn't somehow save west's life
he's he's fixed it up there so getting
him a lot of mileage
okay what's he got here
he's gotta grab the ledge he's gonna
pledge
god
thanks that fateful ballsy ass dropkick
s2j was able to deliver yet another
knockout against his rival closing out
the set in dominating fashion
another another dash that's crazy
it's over he hit him out of the
out of the fell
jump
[Applause]
lucky you knew it was coming so let's
get right into it doing an adorable
little dance towards the penultimate
spot in our list is olofmeister's
infamous burning defuse the defuse is
coming in he's still going oh
just about gets it as the flames come in
and look at the little dance of
happiness in map two of the esl colon
2014 semi-finals fanatic and dignitas
were tied up with the swedes one round
away from sirius point i think there's a
fighting for everything now
let's see what they can do who will get
on
unfortunately fnatic were quickly forced
to play retake as did got the bomb down
and waited to deny the defuse
down two bodies against fnatic's four
digg had to play for time so in an
effort to stall things out device molly
diffuser before executing a monster
rotate while fetish played close
and it was right then just when dick
thought they'd bought themselves a few
seconds of safety that olaf did
something ridiculous
[Music]
around the world we go but the diffuse
the defuse is coming in he's still going
off just about gets it as the flames
come in and look at the little dance of
happiness through the fire and flames
olaf stuck the defuse netting himself
not only the round and the series but
the prestige of having executed the most
truly worth it play in cs go history
jaunting its way into the top spot of
our list is s4's legendary million
dollar dream coil
it's the grand finals of the
international 2013. game five navi are
up assaulting alliance's base and
alliance don't have the strength to
fight back after a coin flippy back and
forth bloodbath it looked as if navi
were about to become two-time ti
champions drop of the mid lane very
quickly i think navi they want to go
high ground they see the victory they
need to claim it 33 seconds if they can
force out a buyback from puck that's
actually there's a buyback there you go
alliance knew that they couldn't stave
off navi's onslaught so they didn't they
used it as bait instead of challenging
navi head on s4 sent his teammates to
flank the side lanes while holding the
line on his own from high ground
and then right as his own barracks fell
just as navi were retreating to stop
their own structures from falling s4
cancelled their tps back to base with a
million dollar maneuver that could be
game blinks away they take the rest
tp quick right now s4 is gonna try to
cancel as many as possible yo cancel
three my god funnicks gonna try to tp
but he's gonna defend against everybody
in one fell swoop navi went from closing
out the match themselves to scrambling
as it slipped through their fingers
the ammo ball the hex is some funny fun
nick's going to go down as well
oh my god i'm not deleted the alliance
is deleted the crazy thing is that s4
wasn't finished they can't roach they
don't have enough damage they don't have
nothing
tp he's oh he cancelled the beat puppy
puppy he's not gonna be back in the face
he's got bkb but no boots of travel boy
a lot
of these tv as well they already
on the back of s million dollar dream
coils alliance were able to execute what
is still considered one of the greatest
comebacks in the history of esports
blown up by the okay creep fighting from
beyond the grave now karaoke sprouted
locked in place but here comes big bad
dendi but no it's too much damage from
loader they want to do it they're going
to do it they're going to do the
alliance wins they
all right folks that's our list if you
think we missed anything let us know
down in the comment section below take
care and i'll see you in the next one
they know that was coming the smokes
come in he's taking a blind shot through
the smoke he'll have to drop back and
find another jewel elsewhere
looks like they want to take over boiler
very quickly and kenny's gonna have some
uh
angry ninjas in his face very soon
oh
that is fast
put that in your pipe and smoke it
i think you'd get pretty high if you did